My oncologist said that I shouldn't take immune stimulator supplements when doing chemotherapy.
Is this true? No, that's not true. The only thing that you shouldn't do when you're as far
as supplement wise, when you're doing chemotherapy, and I would say that you shouldn't do it,
even if you're not doing chemotherapy, it shouldn't take antioxidants because chemotherapy is an
oxidizing agent. That's how it kills cancer. If you're taking antioxidants while you're doing
chemotherapy, you're kind of negating the benefit of the chemotherapy. And you heard me say a
million times that even if you're not doing chemotherapy, most alternative cancer therapies are oxidative.
And if you are taking antioxidants while you're taking those, you're negating the effects of
those possibly. Most therapies to kill cancer are going to be oxidative in nature, not all, but most.
And all therapies to kill cancer need to have an element of immune stimulation.
So if you were taking immune stimulators while taking chemotherapy, while doing chemotherapy,
you would only help the chemotherapy work better. So immune stimulators are not going to
counteract any alternative or standard of care therapy. So many times oncologists will just take this
approach that, okay, you're doing chemotherapy, don't do anything else. You shouldn't do anything
else. I've never heard an oncologist say you shouldn't take an immune stimulator supplements,
although you're doing chemotherapy, that's obvious that oncologist probably
doesn't even know what that means. So I would say that you would just ignore that.
But it's certainly, I think everybody that's trying to treat cancer naturally should, or even
standard of care should be doing lots of things that will stimulate their immune system. It's only
to help everything work better.